viii assertive isms quietism quietism is
a Christian philosophical concept we
should all know about and if it's not
too much of a contradiction talk about
rather loudly why well for something
which has ancient historical roots the
essence of quietas and teachings
favoring disconnection and contemplation
over frantic action is totally modern
and very now in fact quietism could be
regarded as one important antidote to
the age of overload we find ourselves in
quietism says this forget worldly
affairs and just well stop it's not
quite the same as meditation or
mindfulness but there are similarities
and there are parallels with other
faiths - history books will tell you
that quietism began no pun intended
softly and without much fanfare back in
the 4th century Eastern Orthodox
techniques of good old-fashioned
Christian Christ started it all so think
sitting quietly monastic Lee lost in the
act of religious worship but 10
centuries later the 14th century
Byzantine theologians and Gregory
Palamas gave quietism something of a
twist which made it flare into
widespread use and more contentious
territory there was no name as such for
this modern mystical approach back then
but the message was clear instead of
outward displays like religious chanting
and prayer he encouraged contemplation
and stillness of the mind the actual
term quietism was applied later on by
the 17th century Spanish priest Miguel
de molinos a Christian mystic of great
influence again it was controversial he
was denounced as a heretic for
suggesting that quiet internal
reflection and contemplation of God was
okay alongside traditional outward and
vocal displays of religiousness like
chanting and prayer he was
by Pope Innocent xi and died
incarcerated in Rome
in 1696 but suppression of ideas rarely
works and quietism never really went
away the essence of quietism can also be
seen with in many other religions the
Buddhist idea of Dharma has distinctly
quiet istic values with its focus on
connecting a person to their being
rather than what they're doing quietism
is alive and well in modern philosophy
thanks to the 20th century Austrian
British giant athough Ludwig
Wittgenstein and it's influence can be
seen clearly these days in the sea of
mindfulness apps on offer in its more
secular definition quietism is simply a
state of calmness or passivity and who
in this modern rushing overwhelming an
overloaded world doesn't want a bit of
that thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon